now cues at the petrol station may be
annoying for drivers but for governments
they spell big trouble
and if there's also a hint that the
turkeys may not be ready for christmas
the jitters began to turn into panic the
prime minister returned from new york
trumpeting the end of a glorious summer
but he and his ministers could now be
facing a winter of discontent
i'm joined now by the transport
secretary
grant schatz
good morning grant chaps is it fair to
scold motorists uh when buying for panic
buying when all they're trying to do is
to make sure they can get to work
tomorrow morning
yeah and i think the important thing to
know is within the country at the six
refineries and 47 storage facilities uh
there's uh plenty of fuel there's no
shortage of the fuel within the country
uh so the most important thing is
actually that if people carry on as they
normally would and fill up their cars
when they normally would uh then you
won't have queues and you won't have
shortages at the pump either so it's not
like we don't have the fuel in the
current country we do need to just
ensure that people are filling up when
they need to fill up rather than
thinking i better go and fill up now
just in case i need it next week or the
week after
you've been telling people that all week
and it hasn't really made any difference
and actually people are queuing up and
in fact what they're now doing is
driving past
empty uh stations which do not have
petrol so the reassurance is that it's
all going to be okay
absolutely conflicts with people's
actual experience so let me ask you
again
is it
enough just to tell people don't panic
by when they know
that they cannot get petrol in their
cars and get to work tomorrow morning
now i think government has to also
provide the reassurance as well
otherwise as you say people will say
well i can see what's happening with my
own eyes and that's why this morning
we've done a big package of measures
they're short medium and long term uh to
help alleviate the issues which actually
fundamentally come down to one thing
coronavirus
has created massive shortages of lorry
drivers tanker drivers throughout the
world and coronavirus stopped us from
testing them so we can bring new drivers
into the marketplace during the lockdown
so what we've done is doubled the
capacity brought the army in which we've
announced today in order to carry out
more testing so those are short-term
things visas as well in order to plug
the gap between here and christmas and
the medium-term boot camps to train more
people into what is now a much better
paid market apprenticeships and i'm
appealing uh today for a million drivers
who have hgv licenses some of whom have
left the market to come back in
attracted perhaps by those higher wages
and then the long term better uh truck
stops better paying conditions in an
industry which has traditionally been
undercut and hasn't been paying the
salaries that would attract enough
people to the industry so a big package
of measures uh which i hope will help to
reassure people that actually we've got
plenty of fuel if everyone buys it as
they normally would we won't be getting
queues at the petrol stations as well
well look let's let's deal with long
term in a moment but let's talk about
the short term you are issuing just uh 5
500
short term visas for chicken pluckers
and 5000 for qualified hgv
foreign drivers the head of the european
haulage associations says
you haven't got a chance mate they are
not going to come for that money
this is really uh
not going to solve the problem is it
there will not be turkeys for christmas
well i look i i don't agree in terms of
the scale of the um issue they've been
long-term systemic guy who the guy who
represents all the holy drivers you want
to you want to bring back he's telling
you the money is not enough
and by the way our domestic uh halley's
boss is saying we need 90 000 5000
barely a drop in the ocean yeah so
logistics uk who are actually the uk's
biggest uh haulage representative
organization have very much welcomed the
package this morning and do say that
it's a significant uh package it's not
just of course those visas which is very
short term uh it's also the big
bottleneck is there are plenty of people
who know how to drive a lorry but where
they need to get tested or retested uh
dvsa that's the testing agency has had
this massive restriction now you might
say why haven't you acted on that
postcovid in fact we have we reopened
that testing back in april we've managed
to double the capacity partly by using
freedoms that we've got outside of the
eu to change the way the driving tests
work to get more capacity to get more
tests through bringing in the army will
be a very significant assistance there
as well and that way we can get more
people tested and onto the roads so the
visas is only one element of it uh
testing is very much uh front and center
and then of course there's appeal for
people who can already drive to sort of
to realize actually the salaries now
for driving uh lorries has gone up
tremendously we think that's a good
thing we think they've been too many
years of people being undercut to do a
decent day's work
and the fact that people will get paid
properly in this industry is something
which will help it in the long term and
it's actually what's required to have
this industry sustainable in the long
term without constantly having to import
labor uh which is what's happened up
till now
can i put you why people in the industry
are
pretty cross about this they say it's
all too little too late even in the
press release you yourself put out the
boss of the food and drink
confederation
says this is something uk food and drink
manufacturers has asked for have asked
for over the last few months what
they're basically saying is they've been
telling you for months this is gonna
happen and you did nothing
not true uh we have already doubled well
it's in your press release
i'm not making it up it's in your press
release
as i say we've already doubled uh the
capacity so it's just not true that
nothing's been done and let's not
pretend this is sort of you know some uk
specific problem it's not in europe the
some of the for example in poland the
shortage is 123 000 drivers so there
isn't just one simple new point about
itself there isn't one simple solution
to this uh but uh we have despite having
had shortages managed to ensure that
petrol was still getting to petrol
stations food store getting to the shops
i'm afraid there has been some pretty
irresponsible um briefing out by one of
the road haulage associations which has
helped to spark a crisis and that's very
very unhelpful it's counterproductive uh
and uh i know that they're uh desperate
to have more uh
european drivers undercutting british
salaries and that's been their their
their our school along we actually think
that you know it's important that this
country can train people that people can
do a proper day's work that they're paid
properly for that work and that the
long-term solution cannot be
undercutting british salaries
and having a constant cycle a vicious
cycle where you never get out of that
problem of not being able to train
people here and employ them here on
decent salaries
isn't it
forgive me transport secretary isn't it
a little shabby to be blaming everybody
else when actually this arises a choice
you yourself made on august the 5th you
wrote a group of mps
saying and i'm quoting from your letter
i do not support using foreign labor to
tackle a long-standing issue in the
haulage industry you were very specific
that you did not want this to happen you
made a choice
isn't it a little shabby now to be
basically saying oh it's everybody
else's fault when you made that choice
no just once again let me see i do not
believe as i said in that letter that
the long-term solution to britain's
shortages of hgv drivers is to say the
only choice we have is to import
european drivers undercut british
salaries
and not skill up people to do the job
here in the united kingdom so that's
absolutely right i also recognize him
completely pragmatic about this
that we need to ensure that people
are reassured now that this uh
rather sort of
manufactured situation has been created
because as i say there's not petrol in
the country
it's uh it's if everyone goes on the
same day
hang on hang on
manufactured when you say this
manufactured situation manufactured by
whom how
well as i say there was a meeting that
took place about 10 days ago
a private
a private meeting in which one of the
haulage associations decided to leak the
details to
uh to to to the media and that has
created as we have seen uh quite a large
degree of of concern people naturally
react to those things the good news is
as i say there is plenty of fuel the bad
news is if everyone carries on buying it
when they don't need it
then you would continue to have uh cues
sooner or later everyone's cars will be
more or less filled up and there won't
be anywhere else to put fuel it's not
like say the toilet roll crisis at the
beginning of the pandemic where people
could sort of stockpile it it's very
difficult to do that with with fuel um
and so it will come to an end but we
just appeal to people to uh be sensible
fill up when you normally would we've
got this big package in place uh today
in order to help alleviate the pressure
and we ask people to do their part now
we've got this packaging place doing its
part
some people in your own party are pretty
unhappy about this what they're saying
is
you've rolled over on driver shortages
uh and
changed relaxed immigration uh rules uh
so
when you next get
an appeal from farmers
about fruit rotting in the fields or
hospitality bosses about the fact that
they can't hire chefs and waiters
and care home owners about lack of staff
are you all going to roll over again
well it very much supports the point i'm
making which is we don't want to be in a
situation where we are not training
people here and in each of these cases
we need to look to the sectors involved
to make sure we are
they are training up the next
generations and you know in in julia
drivers for example um it's uh
99 male
it's uh average age 55. you know there
is a systemic problem that the
government is very keen to work with the
sector on but the sector will also need
to
help recruit people in and train people
and help improve standards in those in
those sectors so that it's more pleasant
to drive and then in other sectors as
you say there are already schemes that
enable people to come in to pick fruit
it's a seasonal it's a seasonal role but
yes broadly speaking as you suggest we
believe that we should be training
people in this country and that people
should be able to earn a decent wage in
this country and that is absolutely at
the heart of the government's uh
approach which is why even with the visa
to drive lorries it's limited until
christmas
okay um the deputy leader of the labour
party had a colorful description of
uh conservatives um at a party yesterday
evening and she spoke to me this morning
and she made clear that what she really
had in mind was not
all conservative voters or indeed all
conservatives just the cabinet uh
are you okay to be described as scum
i just see it absolutely uh appalling
there's just no place in public life for
that sort of language that sort of
behavior uh i saw that she had described
uh herself as being somebody who wanted
to see a kinder kind of politics uh back
in 2019 and i'm very sorry that seems to
have disappeared i watched your
interview and and literally wondered to
myself is she talking about me here i
i'm just not clear uh and i think it
would have been uh i was talking about
really
i wasn't sure but i'd be much i think
it'd be befitting if she actually just
apologized rather than talked around the
subject
we're coming up to cop 26 uh just very
one quick point because this is really
in your bailiwick um
if we want to get to net zero
we are going to have to stop people
using fossil fuels um will you be
recommending to the chancellor that in
his autumn statement
he raises fuel duty
well the the as you'd expect me to say
in his awesome statement he'll have a
lot of decisions to take and i'm going
to preempt his budget but uh i'm just
asking this because this is your job
would you say to him here's something
you could do
offer
an option
as i say he'll have to come up with
decisions about his awesome budget but
what i can tell you is actually a lot of
people already switching to electric
actually because of the crisis this
weekend i was just checking the latest
numbers there are 700 000 cars in
britain today with plugs on the end of
them uh who will not therefore be
involved in the in in the petrol um
shortage a lot of people are already
switching and in eight years time
there's the end of the pure the sale of
pure petrol and diesel cars uh in any
case so that that movement across is
already taking place we've got a very
big uh transport decarbonization plan in
place which actually uh helps to track
us along that path to zero carbon in in
cars but and then critically in the much
harder to decarbonize parts for
transport which are you know ships but
planes in particular and this country is
leading the way for example with
hydrogen aircraft being tested out at
the moment
grand chaps thank you very much indeed
you're welcome